l'organisation mondiale de la santé
vient d'annoncer que la tuberculose a
rejoint le vih sida comme cause
principale de mortalité dans le monde
près de 10 millions de personnes ont
contracté la maladie en 2014
michel bonsoir vous croyez que la
tuberculose était une maladie du siècle
dernier on l'a elle revient cette
maladie elle revient on l'avait su
contrôler mais depuis 15 ans non pas du
tout c'était en aussi à 4000 personnes
quotidiennement qui meurent de cette
maladie transmissible donc c'est une
bactérie le bassin de coqs qui s'attaque
principalement aux poumons
au milieu du xxème siècle qu'on avait là
soudainement deux armes le vaccin et des
bronzes antibiotiques ce qui s'est passé
dans l'art dans le reste du siècle c'est
qu'il ya une résistance aux
antibiotiques
le vaccin pas nécessairement très
fonctionnelle et/ou aussi beaucoup de
problèmes qui hélas qui la cause
principale les questions d'hygiène
d'éducation et de pauvreté au coeur de
sa donc ceci explique en fait que cette
maladie se hisse à nouveau oui au rang
des premiers tueurs la bruine
regardons ensemble céline donc si on
recule dix ans donc on avait 5 2 4
millions et 1 8 ans seulement on a
presque doublé la mise à près de 10
millions et le nombre de décès et c'est
ça qui inquiète ouais mais c'est vrai
que 5 millions on rejoint là le sida et
il y aurait probablement 100 millions de
porteur de ce bacille de koch dans le
monde et au canada quelle est la
situation
bon on a un bon programme de prévention
et de surveillance au canada 1800
convieront si on regarde justement
l'incidence cinq ans sur 100 milles mais
quand on regarde les autochtones là on
s'inquiète 22 cas sur cent mille et les
inuits à la laverie tab le mans 150 cas
sur cent mille îles ont là-bas des
programmes de prévention et d'éducation
mais on est encore loin d'avoir résolu
le problème si c'est énorme c'est énorme
et ça soulève tout le caisse tout le
questionnement qu'on a revient publié un
avis en disant c'est un problème bio
sociale il faut beaucoup s'attaquer aux
causes de cette maladie là qui sont
vraiment est liée à l'environnement
socio-économique donc de la prévention
de l'éducation de l'hygiène
une bonne nutrition tous ces facteurs la
lutte aussi à la drogue et à l'alcool
tout ça peut améliorer le sort de ces
gens là est peut-être baissé l'incidence
de cette maladie là alors on parle
beaucoup des autochtones
en ce moment ça vient s'ajouter oui
c'est une troisième à tiques qui n'avait
pas du tout ces gens actuellement un
dossier à suivre de près merci beaucoup
michel biau six semaines